what you are about to hear maybe
frightening to younger viewers so please
be advised and use caution if sharing or
recommending to those who are easily
frightened
it's dark out your parents are asleep
you stare at the ceiling in your room as
you have before countless times after a
long hard day of work and play father
will be up early in the morning to feed
the animals and mother will be waking me
for breakfast you think to yourself as
you decide to give in to your weary body
and drift away to sleep as you lean to
your side and close your eyes you feel
something different the air around you
is warmer than normal this time of year
you struggled to find a cooler spot
under your blankets but the heat just
seems to keep building you even think
you smell something burning you open
your eyes to find that the sky has
turned from a night blue to a dark
burning red and out your bedroom window
you see what you think is a person
dancing through the air waving a wand
around their head like a child with a
new toy they dance and dance aimlessly
stepping on nothing but they're getting
closer every step until they stop not
ten yards away from your bedroom window
they see you they're looking at you
they're waving at you you hear their
high-pitched childish laughter as they
stare into your soul with flaming red
eyes and a wide menacing smile that
sends a cold chill down your spine it is
then you notice the fires your neighbors
your grandparents house burning down
with no signs that anyone made it out
just as soon as the horrifying
realization hits you the funny dancing
fire demon disappears from your very
eyes you jump out of bed and rush to
your window coughing on smoke now to see
where the enemy had disappeared to when
suddenly a tree appears right outside
your window the only separation
big sheet of alas you stumble backward
and fall eyes locked on the burning
pupils of the monster grinning at you
outside your window and you realize your
room no your entire house is engulfed in
flames to grate to escape you are
overcome with terror as you watch your
toys and your family portraits turn to
ash before your very eyes must think
you're able to see and hear is the
sickening smile childish laughing of
your murder as you drift away to sleep
forever
to the east of Death Mountain lies a low
Valley known as the shadow pass home to
lush forestry wildlife and some minor
enemies but up the side of the volcanic
Mountain between the two locations not
quite high enough to burn your skin off
due to the heat from Death Mountain but
also not low enough to be easily
accessed by enemies and monsters lies a
quiet quaint little ruins called the
shadow hamlet ruins it's surrounded by
giant protective rocks and a good amount
of trees there is grass growing
vibrantly among the ruins as well if you
look to the surrounding terrain the soil
appears black and lifeless making the
green grass under shadow Hamlet ruins
stand out as rather odd there are also
trees present among the ruins where
there are none otherwise it's almost as
if whoever lived in these ruins tended
to the grounds growing crops and fruit
trees as a way of life there were three
buildings here which due to the
positioning and size of settlement we
can only assume are mostly houses and
maybe a stables or outdoor storage house
besides the one flying enemy we find at
the location and a couple of fireproof
lizards there are no other living
creatures in the ruins everything except
the green grassy ground appears to have
been burnt to a crisp and that's just
the thing the ground isn't burnt
if this burning was a case of a lava
eruption from the volcano the ground
should look black and charred the same
as the surrounding terrain not green and
luscious know the way the structures and
trees are still standing appears to be
the work of a fire not lava now while
it's possible that an accidental fire
was set off dooming the residents of the
small settlement I don't think that's
the likely situation when we consider
the flying enemy that's present dancing
around among the ruins we begin to see
that it's of no coincidence at all so
The Legend of Zelda has monsters I mean
lots of monsters for more than three
decades now we've been playing these
games and getting to know the enemies
and monsters that repeatedly make
appearances throughout the series one of
these monsters that has been there since
the very start is the wizzrobe these
oddly behaving robe wearing magic
wielding monsters are present in nearly
every Zelda game to date including the
most recent title we know as breath of
the wild for over two years now
I've thought of these enemies in the
game as simply another kind of annoying
monster to defeat in order to progress
through the game but when I stumbled
upon the mysteriously hidden shadow
Hamlet ruins I began to think
differently something about seeing this
fire magic wielding enemy dancing around
the charred remains of what used to be a
small peaceful village seemed off to me
it seemed murderous let's look at this a
bit closer and theorize on what could
have happened to these settlers Wiz
ropes are voluntarily a part of Ganon's
army how do I know that well of course
it hasn't been confirmed but thinking
logically about it it's the only thing
that makes sense to me
Ganon's armies have often been comprised
of the same kinds of mindless enemies
over the years but Cobbins moblins
lizalfos and the like are all enemies
that are racially bound to ganon and his
wiles now what I mean by that is it
seems like the only appearances of these
enemy races is when they are enemies to
Lincoln Zelda and therefore we can
conclude that these enemy races are
either eternally cursed to follow Ganon
manipulate it into it or created
entirely to follow Ganon kind of like
the or acai from the middle-earth
universe however Wiz robes are seen to
be different races throughout the
different games they're featured in in
Wind Waker they're bird-like almost as
if a part of the rito tribe in majora's
mask in the original Legend of Zelda
game they appear to be humanoid with
long witch-like fingernails and noses
and in breath of the wild the art we can
see in the book creating a champion
reveals that under the robes they're
also human ish this tied with the fact
that they're actually intelligent beings
being able to knowledgeably wield magic
and use it for advanced tactics against
link and being shown to dance around
playfully when not in combat and even
smile and wave at link when they see him
communica Blee leads me to believe that
they are not bound to Ganon but rather
are powerful magic wielding beings from
all sorts of different races that choose
to side with Ganon for
whatever promise of dark power he offers
I mean look at their smiles it looks to
me like they enjoy what they do
knowing this does it make much sense to
give whiz robes the same job as pecans
whose only real purpose is to run around
aimlessly and make a presence due to
overwhelming numbers but Cobbins and
modeling's don't have any real task they
simply guard locations or roam about
seeking food because let's face it when
you save random civilians from these
monsters they're probably just after a
good bite to eat or something it's
entirely possible that Wiz robes being
intelligent creatures would be given a
different task one that involves
clearing out harder to reach human
settlements or more fortified ones why
is it we always seem to find Wiz robes
dancing about in ruins could it be that
they are the ones who destroyed who ever
lived there initially creating the ruins
by Ganon's request now bringing this
back to the shadow hamlet ruins I
believe that a small family decided to
live there to escape from the dangers
below this must have been after the
calamity Ganon unleashed his attack on
Hyrule as we see the ground around the
settlement is burnt and destroyed
meaning the volcano had probably begun
acting up and they moved to a very hard
to reach location off of the ground
level meaning there were probably
monsters lurking the fields of Hyrule
below but for whatever reason it was a
small family had moved here to hide away
from the horrors below and have a
peaceful life farming for themselves one
day ganon's forces caught wind of where
they were living and a media wizra was
dispatched to destroy them
since the wizzrobe is still dancing
around the ruins who knows how long it's
been there who knows of this event only
took place just recently what if link
could have saved them if he had only
arrived sooner we'll never know for sure
and the mysterious families ruins will
forever scarred Death Mountain this is
of course just a theory but what did you
think did this wizzrobe earn the
innocent family living in shadow hamlet
or something else
hey guys masculine henna bandit here and
thanks so much for watching the video
please leave a like if you enjoyed
watching and want to see more like this
and subscribe if you haven't already for
much more top-notch zelda content to
come thank you once again to all my
patreon supporters I love you guys so
much if you're interested in supporting
the channel please feel free to check
the link in the description below to
check out the different support tiers or
to join our growing discord server
that's all I've got for you so without
further adieu have a great rest of your
day
[Music]